this week we're talking about the
essentials of reliability engineering
and how to improve Identity and Access
Management I'm max Saltonstall welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news so your app is
scaling up swiftly to meet audience
adoption great but continuing to add
engineers to your ops team not so great
this week hear the story of how Google
originally solved this problem as our
own network grew but developing an
intuitive set of site reliability
engineering principles then spare
yourself the trial and error and learn
from our mistakes when it comes to
application security your safety relies
on managing who in your org gets access
to which resources but the right answers
aren't always obvious read about
applying the principles of least
privilege to improve your security
posture learn our top tips for
minimizing the surface area of exposed
applications and see which can make the
biggest difference for you speaking of
access the new Identity and Access
Management recommender for GCP can
automatically detect overly permissive
access policies then it generates
suggested adjustments to your
permissions based on the access patterns
of similar people in your organization
read the full article to learn how
recommenders work then try them out
yourself the discovery and assessment
phase of cloud migration projects tends
to predict whether the migration will
succeed or fail read this post to learn
about two tools that can make a big
difference
stratas own and risk networks then head
over to the walkthroughs to see how each
one works in practice if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link have
any questions leave a comment or tweet
us we'll see you in the cloud
you